yeah remember that scene on Euphoria
when Rue played by Zendaya escapes rehab
by running through her neighborhood and
hiding in a trash can
Well turns out that dark moment was
actually full of laughter on set
[Music]
all right connector it's just one of
many funny bits we see in the Euphoria
season 2 blooper reel when Angus Cloud
accidentally calls his co-star Chloe
Cherry by her name instead of her
character's name this this is Chloe
I mean
joke around and like make weird noises
and they're so funny like Angus would
have me laughing like when I was not
supposed to be laughing like too much oh
my God knew it was so funny Alexa Demi
who plays Maddie isn't British on the
show or in real life but uh seems she
likes working on her accent in between
takes just having a little fun can you
do a British accent uh say Maddie
say Maddie you are such a good player
not your such a good player a season two
highlight that stunning Montage of Jules
and Rue reenacting classic love stories
from Iconic films they played out
beautifully on the show but while
filming the ladies had a serious case of
the giggles
[Music]
how about we get that
it was a good girl for me
despite the show being so dark and
intense it's nice to see the actors
having a good time while filming
[Music]
beautiful oh that was so cute
for Zendaya working on a heavy show like
Euphoria her boyfriend Tom Holland helps
her keep things light was it meant to
have someone like Tom to help pull you
out of those dark moments as real I
think
that to to free you up from it every now
and then and as we look forward to the
hit series upcoming third season we're
full of questions about what's next
[Music]
what we do know we've likely Seen the
Last of ashtray I do think Ash is dead
you know I'm not positive but most
likely yeah you know I've been working
on a lot of other things recently and um
I I as much as I loved Euphoria I've
moved on you know that's totally fair
and uh I love everybody there though and
Chloe well she wants her character Faye
to step up in a major way I want to see
Faye like really like help I wanna I
would what I would want to say I don't
know yet but I would love to see Faye
like help Rue in some way I don't know I
I don't want I really don't want Rue to
die so even though we're gonna have to
wait a minute for season three please
tell me we don't have to wait until 2024
for season three what do you know no you
might have to wait 10 years it takes a
long time yeah we'll stay busy by
re-watching season two and watching this
hilarious moment on a loop
foreign